When I was about six or seven years old,
I was flipping channels on the television.
It was Monday night raw.
The very first thing I see Jeff Perry guitar over someone's head.
I don't know who was
six year old.
Holy,
that's what I want to do.
My name is [inaudible] and I'm a rapper.
People come up to me,
you know,
there'll be like,
wow,
why are you not huge?
Did this,
here's my matchup tonight.
The 1% trial,
Nelson and Roy,
size X.
Yeah,
we'll never hurt you that look better.
So when it comes to nutrition,
I spend so much freaking money on food.
I live by myself and it's saint.
It's filled with dishes like on a daily basis,
fam.
I just need to know for sure what time we're going to be here because I'm taking
two o'clock
I have a tag team partner.
His name is Roy size.
It's you and I go by the 1% which is the whole idea behind the name does that we
looked better than 99% of the rest of the world.
Yeah.
Jack,
you want to watch Dora or Daniel?
I'm always told myself I'm going to do music.
Okay.
Very hard.
When me an independent Isp,
you had this voice and want to shout that your life in this womb and nobody
hears you.
Sometimes I'm eating with my friends and even my family members and I'm just
like,
what do I talk about?
They all like all so she just doing that and I'm just like,
yeah,
I'm sorry.
You know I'm doing an album,
right?
I was going on for her adoption.
My parents didn't name me,
so I was put into a foster home
based off of my adoption papers.
My foster mother named me Hassan.
I got into church a lot and I was praying a lot.
My mom was getting worried,
you know,
and a lot of it was my identity issues,
professional wrestling.
If you break it down to the ground level,
it's a,
it's heroes versus villains.
For the most part.
The wrestling is all about the moments that you can create.
If he can get the fans to invest in those moments.
Are you a,
you're ever feeling?
I am a bad guy,
100% in real life.
They're going to sleep.
Okay.
I've been doing this since I was like 17
okay.
I saw will Smith on camera and I'm,
oh my gosh,
she's cute.
So then I would just follow his life and then I started like in hip hop because
of that.
All right.
Just to check herself out.
That's enough of that to find some food,
man.
There's a reason why I buy a Dave's killer bread and bagels.
11 grams of protein per Bagel,
49 grams of carbs.
Peanut butter.
That's what I need God to go the natural,
I don't know why.
You know what?
I'm gonna check this out right now.
I bet there's not even a single thing different with this.
Any difference in the price?
Nope.
That's how you know,
there ain't shit different with it.
Yeah,
we're in Jersey right now and I have a show in Maryland.
It's for the first lady of Maryland and it's actually like a cultural
celebration for,
um,
for adopting.
I'm assuming she's going to give me the check today for my,
my honorarium,
but because it's like the governor,
you know,
there's a lot of things that come into play.
I think it's age.
So you started out?
Yeah,
it's Nep.
I was calculating a recently,
if I do all of the songs that I,
you know,
six songs,
it costs roughly around like almost 7,000 for just reporting and to do the
promotions,
music videos,
off photo shoots.
This EAP would probably caused them as 15,000 everything costs money and even if
it's sometimes it's just 80 bucks a year,
$200 there,
you turn around and you spend almost a thousand dollars.
Do you know how much of banana costs?
Well in Los Angeles,
white lunch and Washington state one from like 17 cents of time since then,
but now I don't,
I couldn't tell you like I know for sure how much I Samsung Gout to.
Yes.
If I bought it outright,
that's like 600 $700 and you just asked me how much banana toss that I eat every
day.
I'm,
I don't know,
penny.
That'd be great.
Probably going to get burger king.
We'll see.
It's the cheapest though.
56 gosh,
next second leftover.
When you go on these,
these road trips and stuff,
it's kind of hard when I see burger king or I see a fast food place,
like I ultimately just want to get it because I love fries and burgers and
stuff.
So it's very hard for me not to go
my pre workout straight to the dome.
I even shake it with water.
Who needs water?
State it.
Oh we beautiful right now
for them keeping the
where they come
from.
God.
Then it's ready to charge it hard.
I don't care what they think and I can't just work on my thesis
cause I never will set a wielder but like a nap.
Just the best deal done for the teeth to bed.
I will live for the to do,
but I will put a lot of just my skills set.
Me going on out
my wrestling boots.
This is our gold pair.
1% this one's falling apart though.
Here's our purple one.
These cost us $50 a pair.
So $250 right there with the rest of them do.
Yeah.
Okay
ma'am.
What?
I'm sexy man.
Doug,
look at this,
my checking account and we'll go really low and I'm like,
okay Tim,
you can't take any money out for the next two weeks.
You know,
I'm not blaming Tim because he has a great job.
He works really hard.
We've been doing,
I tried to get some over time and I give it to get some extra money to help with
finding music videos or social media stuff.
No days.
Me and some of just sitting at home and it's like,
Yo,
I time I need to get a job and it's not that neat but I can't get a job.
I'm taking care of my two kids and if I take care of,
if I get a job,
I got to put one of them in daycare and that kind of like would totally just x
out of my pay check anyway.
What are you going to,
this is for later,
but if you want one you can have one.
I'll get
the pain of buying stuff.
I don't need,
there's $10 in the Livingston.
Both the bang.
I just feel like later on I might need that little extra kick.
Have you heard your daily [inaudible]
well if you drink this you would.
Can you guys all know how much money each other making tonight?
Oh I know how much Royce is making cause I set up the book and Royce and I
agreed on a hundred each.
So you're making a hundred I like at one 20 I asked for extra swipe.
Do you guys feel that you're a compensated appropriately for like the work that
you put your bodies through here?
I would say
absolutely not.
I think guys like
us,
we put in a lot of work.
We're on the road a lot with just driving early mornings.
Even the most basic simple wrestling move you can lose your life if you compare.
Even like when we get paid compared to like stop and stuff like that where
they're in a controlled environment.
There's multiple takes,
there's padding,
there's harnesses,
whatever.
Like now we're just like out there.
Everyone involved in wrestling.
You should be getting paid more.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
It's on like a punch or maybe don't throw punches in your mind.
Is that okay?
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
[inaudible]
wow.
Yeah.
I was
just,
do I base my success off of,
am I selling out stadiums?
Am I going on tours?
I saw like a lot of adoptive parents,
they were smiling when I was up there and hopefully when I meet with them later,
they're going to say,
wow,
like you're like inspiring.
It's a roller coaster.
What we do,
we take people through the emotional journey with the physical impact of
storytelling.
Great shirts to work.
I may not have made $1 million today.
Oh,
not a billion,
but I may go home and still struggle with money.
I may still wonder when my next show is going to be,
but when I do get that show,
you get those
people coming up to you.
You know?
That's why you kind of do it.
A lot of us are sit in the car drive,
however miles will we wake up with pain of course,
but do we love it?
Hell yeah.
Thank
you guys.
You guys aren't on Instagram,
or
maybe if your kids want to,
they're into hip hop,
you know,
listen to,
it's a great day today.
I love doing shows like this.
You kind of don't know what to expect.
I got people jumping and Sharon and having a great time and you just would never
expect to see certain people doing that,
especially to hip hop.
So
we worked harder than anyone in that room tonight.
Come on,
you know,
back to the grind,
doing what I do,
making music,
performing,
and you know,
it's kind of like you hit repeat and keep doing this and keep hoping for the
best.
Or
was it
four 30 this is the most expensive article I've ever been to in my life.
I didn't even get up.
I didn't even get a full check.
Nine gallons,
nine gallon.
I'm triggered.
You're very true.
I've been shut.
Hoodwink I've been railroaded.
Buffalo.